the old float too or will you nobody
really knows whether we'll ever get to
see it's chapter three but it's not
looking great here's why since franchise
potential is everything these days many
filmmakers and their stories with the
henta audiences might one day return to
that world however in Chapter 2 saves
largely faithful to the source material
Stephen King wrote the novel as a
standalone story with a definitive
beginning middle and end and the IT film
series respects these main beasts even
if it takes creative Liberties in other
sections in the end the losers perform a
ritual and tear out pennywise's heart
Bringing Down the curtain on the Unholy
Clown's reign of terror their Victory
isn't without a cost though since Eddie
dies of his wounds in the final battle
or the friends lost Stan early in the
film in the book a devastating storm
watches over Derry but this event is
missing from the movie leaving the
audience with a more hopeful end to the
story looking at the narrative from an
objective point of view the story of it
is over after chapter two these
characters have suffered overcome and
prevailed after all is said and done
ultimately they have arrived at their
final destination while it might be
tempting to start a new journey in it
chapter 3 there needs to be a truly
compelling reason to revisit Derry and
revive Pennywise especially after he
suffered such a final end while it isn't
unusual for different directors to help
various installments in a Trilogy it's
chapter 3 wouldn't feel the same without
Andy muskete his vision for the series
is unique and his signature horror style
can be felt in every part of the movies
to replace him would be akin to
replacing the very soul of the film
franchise unfortunately muskete has
never seen it as a three-film franchise
even after the incredible success of the
2017 film the filmmaker explained how
there was never any intention to stretch
out the story longer than necessary he
told variety how he had read about the
trilogy idea but insisted there was
never any discussion about it muskete
said I understand what they would think
about because new line originally splits
up The Hobbit into three movies instead
of two but to be honest I wasn't a
conversation about that and now we are
regarding the story as one single film
it's also telling that a studio resisted
a temptation to make an extra film and
squeeze more money out of the franchise
especially after the impressive box
office Hall of the first movie
a picture wrap on Bill Skarsgard let's
give him a half
a return to Derry wouldn't be complete
without the return of Bill Skarsgard as
Pennywise while there was initially some
debate surrounding whether Skarsgard
would do the character Justice no one
can dispute the active but his own
menacing Twist on Stephen King's
Infamous demon and despite having two it
movies under his belt it appears as if
Skarsgard wasn't ready to let the
Dancing Clown go yet either after the
release of it chapter 2 Skarsgard
revealed to Joe Blow how he and Andy
muskete had discussed the possibility of
a third film both of them acknowledge
how it would need to be an entirely
original story since they had mostly
covered the events of the novel
Skarsgard said there are a few ideas
floating around I feel like I've done
what I can with the Incarnation of
Pennywise as we know of him so I think
it would be a cool idea to change up a
few things so without going into too
much detail there is a story that we're
kind of excited about but it's way too
early to say who knows the story of it
better than anyone else the author of
the novel of course Stephen King while a
continuation of it has never
materialized in a literary world the
writer has shown he isn't afraid of
returning to his former stomping grounds
when inspire racing strikes most
recently he released dog to sleep a
sequel to 1977's The Shining 36 years
after the original many fans wonder if
he will give Edge the same treatment
especially take it into account
pennywise's plays in pop cultures
Zeitgeist appearing on Bloody
disgusting's losers Club podcast King
acknowledged how Pennywise is closely
tied to his own legacy as a writer even
joking about how the clown will one day
Eclipse him that being said he isn't
itching to get back into this world well
I don't have a relationship with
Pennywise now because I I have no
intention of going back to it King
revealed some further contexts about the
upcoming welcome to Dairy series stating
it will be a prequel set before the
events of the first movie and explore
the backstory of Pennywise the author
wasn't opposed to the idea either
admitting there are more than a few
intriguing storytelling possibilities to
explore in the future Gary Dobermann has
built up a formidable reputation as one
of the hottest Horror filmmakers in
Hollywood he wrote all of the Annabelle
movies and even directed the third entry
in the franchise Annabelle comes home
government also had a hand in shape in
the direction of the it film series
co-writing the first film and taking on
the whole screenplay for chapter two
Dobermann also had his own ideas of
power potential it's chapter 3 could
develop the story further and Tackle
King's Rich lore speaking to
comicbookmovie.com Doberman discussed
how the two movies are limited to how
much mythology can be covered and
insists that there is a lot more to
explore especially in terms of the
antagonist he said there are definitely
elements of the novel you could expand
on and make its own movie it's just a
question of whether or not people want
to see it but I do think it was on this
planet for a very very long time and
that's a lot of Bloodshed and a lot of
stories to tell and I think you could do
that for sure for all intents and
purposes the cosmic entity known as it
is dead after the ritual in which
Pennywise had his heart ripped out this
should be a done-ingested case of Ding
Dong the clown is gone however this is
Zara genre but death is anything but
final there are several ways of bringing
back Pennywise and it's up to the
writers to figure out how regardless of
how it's done it's important to revive
the main antagonists of the franchise
whether it comes back in the form of a
clown or something else entirely
considering the importance of 27-year
intervals to the story its chapter 3
should take place 27 years later and in
Derry of course nobody in the losers
Club has any kids so this could also be
a chance to pass the mantle to a new
group of characters to carry the story
forward naturally one or two of the
original losers could return and help
out but a third installment should offer
a brand new Journey for brand new
characters not a rehash of what came
before so what would a car look like for
a third it movie well if Andy muskete
Helms it's chapter 3 it's obvious that
there must be one name at the top of the
cast list Phil Skarsgard taking on this
version that the story would feel
strange without skarsgard's involvement
even if he portrays another incarnation
of the character time to flow in
addition it will be essential to bring
back at least one of the surviving
losers in terms of sheer drawing power
and star credentials that instantly
points the two actors Jessica Chastain
and James McAvoy considering that
Chastain's Bev married Jay Ryan's Ben at
the end of it chapter 2 it's also likely
that he would make an appearance
alongside her regardless if it was
chosen it will play into the movie's
Trends to include at least one of the
original characters from The Beloved
group thus assuming of course that any
of these actors would be willing and
available to return for chapter three as
with any fandom there are mixed feelings
among fans about continuing the story of
it a good portion of the audience has
read Stephen King's novel and likely
believes that the largely faithful
adaptation captures the book's tone and
message meaning there is absolutely no
need to beat this dead clown over and
over again at the same time there are
others who are curious about how the
story could continue and explore more
about Pennywise as long as it is done in
a gripping Manner and doesn't embarrass
The Source material in one thread posted
on Reddit both sides of the fandom aired
their opinions about whether or not the
franchise should continue one commenter
suggested that the very notion of it
chapter 3 is terrible fan service and
insisted that there is no need to
continue the story they even argued that
a third movie could turn Pennywise into
more of a caricature than a monster
another redditor said it's the losers
club that is a heart and soul of it
meaning a third movie would feel weird
without them as the main characters one
user saw both sides of the argument
writing part of me wants to see more
Pennywise but the other part remembers
that it was the cast as a whole that
made me love chapter one and two plus a
little bit of mystery in the origin of
Pennywise is what makes a character
interesting it was no secret that Warner
Brothers have been eyeing a prequel for
its since the release of chapter 2.
perhaps that's no surprise considering
the fans reacted so positively to the
scene in which Pennywise is shown in his
human form without any clown maker
hinting there might be more to his past
can section with the town of Derry close
your eyes
and sure enough in February 2023 it was
finally confirmed that the horror story
will continue as a prequel series for
Max titled welcome to Derry according to
an article published by The Hollywood
Reporter this prequel comes from the
minds of Andy and Barbara muskete and
Jason Fuchs it will reveal more of Derry
and explore why the town is survived the
Sinister happenings Fuchs and Brad Caleb
Kane are said to be co-show Runners for
the show while muskete is scheduled to
direct multiple episodes while the news
have welcomed the dairy excited those
who would like to see more of muskete's
version of it some unfortunate news
arrived soon after in an interview with
Jake's takes Bill Skarsgard confirmed he
hadn't been asked to return for the
series as Pennywise at least not at that
time this was a surprising turn of
events especially considering how
pivotal Skarsgard have been to the film
series success then again since it is a
shapeshifter it's not outside the realm
of possibility for Pennywise of a
different face and thus assuming
Skarsgard was even telling the truth
taking into account Andy musketti's
involvement and welcome to Derry is
looking highly unlikely that it's
chapter 3 will ever materialize at least
not as a movie without being said
muskete has admitted that he would like
to do something different with the two
it films helping to create a super-sized
version of both of these features as
well as something a little more chatting
with Cinema Blend the filmmaker
explained how he wants to include what
was shot and omitted from the theatrical
curse while also filming new footage he
said I am thinking of a Supercar which
is basically the two movies told one
after the other adding everything that
was lifted from them in length purposes
great scenes that are more character
moments or things that we had to lift
for other reasons I'm also very excited
about shooting extra material for fans
this might sound like an interesting
proposition in the same vein of The Lord
of the Rings extended editions neither
it film was particularly short either
the first movie clocked in at 135
minutes while the sequel was longer at
169 minutes meaning this super cut could
become a behemoth of a feature who knows
maybe with all the cutscenes and
additional footage this could be
considered a kind of third chapter in
the it story